we're here with James Davis and this is
celebrity fashion surgery hello hey guys
it is like a wound and not really like a
nice to you situation what would you do
well I mean I'm loving this camo there's
so much I love about a street style but
the great shoes James you didn't have
better sneakers to wear your shoes
alright the top Jordan that came out the
shoes they might be Jordan but they
grave is a great opportunity self a pop
of color on that always lab one item to
plug yo what's that TV show hoodie J's
with James Davis thing on your neck
playing on years where's the bling on
your finger I haven't met that special
someone are you looking are you looking
Jerry I'm you know looking but I'm not
looking to like focus on like one bang
at this juncture in my journey
romantically in the tail soon every
relationship burn relax I'm sorry it's
only fair that we've critiqued your
outfit why don't you give us a go I love
Majesta you look like lipsticks wrapped
in saran wrap I'll take that as a
compliment
Oh your shoes afresh with either a size
10 James in the hood when anyone asks
what your size is you can say my thighs
because it just causes my side I might
want to take from a do this again what
size is your shoes the nice size James
Oh respectful you can have them I would
drop the bottom of his jacket a little
bit lower I'm most proud Popish right
here it stopped very suddenly everything
else is great you're here I get a minus
a 92% and I'm an M
mm and I'm at that's enough that I've
never been given an a-minus before in my
life so I would like to say what is your
shoe size James well I thought oh me
[Music]